هل يمكن ان تطلعنا على ما توفر لديك من
تفاصيل حتى اللحظه وعن حقيقه الرد من
جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين نعم خلال العمليه التي شنتها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبريطانيا تم استهداف قاعده الديلمي شمال
صنعاء وايضا محيط مطار الحديده ومناطق
ايضا في الزبي
و ومعسكر كهلان شرقي صعده فهذا الهجوم دفع
ايضا وزير الخارجيه او نائب وزير خارجيه
انصار الله الحوثيين
بان يتحدث بان اليمن تعرضت لعدوان وانه
لابد من دفع
الثمن يبدو ان الاستهداف التي الذي شنه
انصار الله في التاسع من يناير والذي
اكدوا انهم سببوا دمارا او ضررا في
السفينه الحربيه الامريكيه كما اكد ايضا
زعيم جماعه انصر الله عبد الملك الحوثي
خلال خطابه
اليوم بان هذا الهجوم الذي استخدم فيه ما
يقارب 24 مسيره وتحدثت القياده المركزيه
التابعه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه بانها
اسقطت 18 مسيره بانه يبدو في حديثه يكتفي
بالضرب
التي تلقتها هذه السفينه الحربيه واكد
بانه لو حدث اي استهداف اخر من قبل امريكا
و وحلفها فان ضرباتهم القادمه ستكون اكثر
سيستخدمون فيها اكثر عددا اكثر من
الصواريخ واكثر وسيكون ايضا الايلام اكثر
فيما ايضا خلال هذا الاستهداف الذي تنوع
في مناطق مختلفه من صنعاء
وذمار والحديده وصعده وتعز يؤكد ايضا
مسؤولون حوثيون ايضا بانهم سيستهدف ايضا
حتى تلك المناطق التي انطلقت منها هذه
الطائرات
وايضا تلك البوارج
التي موجوده في البحر الاحمر هناك من يؤكد
بانه حتى الان تم اطلاق ما يقارب 200
اي صاروخ او ما يسمى
ب لا نعرف ما نوعيه الصواريخ الي استخدمت
بس لكن يؤكد بانه تم استهداف بعض البوارج
البحريه في البحر الاحمر نحن هنا رساله
كان اطلقها زعيم جماعه انصار الله لم تصل
الى مراكز صنع القرار في بريطانيا وامريكا
نحن الان في واجهه جديده كان قد ربما س
سيكتفي جماعه انصار الله بتلك العمليه في
التاسع من يناير ولكن الان عمليه جديده
قامت بها بريطانيا وامريكا كما نسمع بانها
تريد ان ترسل رسائل الى اي قاده جماعه
انصار الله بان يتوقفوا عن
عملياتهم ومنع السفن الذاهبه الى الموانئ
الاسرائيليه لكن كما نسمع من خلال
التصريحات التي تصلنا بانه لا لن لن لن
يمنع هذا الاستهداف جماعه انصار الله من
الاستمرار من منع سفن اسرا الذي التي
تذهبوا الى اسرائيل بانهم يعتبرون هذا
الموقف موقف انساني لمنع الجرائم التي
لا زالت ومستمره ولازالت ترتكبها اسرائيل
بحق الاهالي غزه ويعتبرون بانها ذلك واجب
انساني ويطالبون بان امريكا وبريطانيا بان
لا تصعد في هذا الامر و و تعسكر البحر
الاحمر بحيث قد ربما في بعض من المتحدثين
التابعين لجماعه انصار الله يهددون بانه
سيتوقف كليا المرور والملاحه في البحر
الاحمر ويؤكدون بان لديهم القدره والامكان